on parle beaucoup des drones par les
temps qui courent et de leurs
possibilités
pas mal immense en illimité je dirai ce
que ces drones peuvent améliorer la
santé des populations qui sont isolées
quand il ya un projet qui est menée
actuellement par des chercheurs de
l'université stony brook à new york et
les stups asteur il explore
l'utilisation de drones dans des
villages isolés au malawi au sénégal à
madagascar également là où se trouve le
pré vite et ce matin docteur simon grand
jean lapierre un médecin et chercheur au
centre de recherche du chum
bonjour doc la matière parlez nous de ce
projet qui implique des drones au malawi
au sénégal et à madagascar
bon en fait c'est plusieurs projets
comme dans plusieurs pays différents
les drones sont technologie qui est qui
n'est plus très jeune mais qui sait pour
laquelle on a de peu de d'expérience et
puis nous ici à madagascar avec des
collègues du sénégal et de malawi on a
tenté un peu de mettre notre expérience
en commun et puis de voir comment ces
drones ont été utilisés dans différents
contextes
est ce qu'on fait ici à madagascar ben
c'est une des formes d'utilisation de
drones c'était du transport à la fois
d'échantillons médicaux et de traitement
dans le cadre des soins sur la
tuberculose mais on se rend compte que
depuis déjà 2014 avec nos collègues de
médecins sans frontières
les drones sont utilisés comme vous le
disiez le donner pour une perspective
d'application qui est presque infini
incluant en santé et puis ça ça peut
vouloir dire simplement de la
surveillance pour préparer une réponse
d'urgence ou identifier les conséquences
d'un sinistre peut vouloir dire de la
chaîne d'approvisionnement pour
permettre d'approvisionner des régions
éloignées en vaccins en traitement en
outils diagnostiques et dans le cas
actuel les trois pays que vous
mentionnez le sénégal malawi et
madagascar utilisent les drones de façon
bidirectionnelle c'était une application
un peu particulière au sens où ce sont
des drones qui peut faire du trans
mais aussi atterrir sur site pour
pouvoir collecter des prélèvements puis
un peu faire le pont entre des systèmes
de laboratoire des infrastructures de
soins de santé
et puis des populations qui sont très
enclavées pour lesquels l'accès aux
soins
oui donc c'est vraiment tout un tout un
projet que vous faites là donc c'est
vraiment pour tenter de contrer la
tuberculose
vous allez chercher les échantillons
vous en voyez aussi des médicaments
c'est ça en effet dans ce projet pilote
laon ce focus sur la tuberculose la
tuberculose on a tendance à l'oublier
mais c'est une bactérie c'est la
bactérie qui tue encore le plus d'êtres
humains sur la planète de façon annuelle
devant toutes les autres causes
infectieuses avant le vih la malaria est
le problème
un des problèmes qu'on a dans l'autre la
tuberculose c'est que sur les 10
millions de cas qui sont estimés su
revenir chaque année il y en a presque 4
millions qu'on n'est pas capable de
trouver donc c'est des cas qui continue
de transmettre qui entretiennent
l'épidémie et puis dans le contexte de
madagascar où les populations l'accès
très difficile au système de soins
mais l'utilisation entre autres de
drogue mais aussi d'autres technologies
qui permettent de suivre
l'adhérence au traitement et puis de
dispenser de la formation avec des
applications mobiles dans des villages
ruraux mais on essaie d'aller recruter
ces patients allocution aux marocains et
puis qui n'ont pas accès au second et
vous êtes là pour combien de temps vous
à madagascar
enfin moi j'ai vécu à madagascar déjà
depuis deux ans et maintenant je suis de
retour en partenariat avec le centre de
recherche du chum et donc on construit
un programme de recherche avec le chum
et l'institut pasteur madagascar avec un
évidement d'autres collaborateurs à
l'international et je partage mon temps
entre madagascar et montréal afin de
pouvoir un peu court donné ce programme
là qui est un programme basé entre comme
je disais entre le centre de recherche
du chum et l'institut pasteur
mais qui est très translationnelle qui
inclut des technologies qu'on vienne
discuter mais qui ce focus aussi sur
différentes
un spot du parfum santé publique et de
diagnostic de laboratoire notamment
séquençage de l'adn pour mieux
comprendre la transmission de la maladie
dans lé même comme une autre et très
rurale où on tente d'éliminer la
tuberculose mieux vous souhaite beaucoup
de succès de père simon grand jean
lapierre
andreck de madagascar ce matin merci
beaucoup merci à vous rejoindre